well that that sounded really impressive
with laura laura i read out all those
like qualifications and what i do
but i didn't
just start out that way so my talk today
is a little bit of a motivational
speech about anybody
can get to where i am if you just put
your
time and effort into finding ways to
kind of
get involved and um improve your skill
sets
so um i do have to say that because i
work for an ngo now like my the views
and opinions are
only my views and opinions and they're
not a representation of any organ
organization to which i currently belong
or i have previously belonged
okay so i'm going to walk you guys
through my little a little bit of my
life story and then give you at the end
uh
talk about lessons learned so in order
to kind of give you guys a bigger
picture i'm just going to talk about
being a scientist
and then switching from being a
scientist to becoming a bioinformatics
faculty member at a university and then
realizing that wasn't a fit and then
moving on to
working in bioinformatics full-time
mainly with cloud um content
and then of course we all kind of
experienced the pandemic so what does
that do to our careers how does that
look like and then is this an
opportunity not not something that hurt
us